good morning Minneapolis temperatures in
the Superbowl City are expected to top
out today at 20 degrees and tomorrow on
game day it will be even colder the
players and fans will be happy that the
game is being played indoors but the
Twin Cities is providing a the game
they're hosting for the country's
premier sporting event they are hosting
it in Minneapolis Jamie yuccas is at the
NFL experience in downtown Minneapolis
good morning Jamie
good morning it's all about layering
right and both NFL teams playing in the
Super Bowl happened to be from
cold-weather cities so that's a good
thing but when you're talking about high
temperatures in the single digits it's a
freeze not a lot of people have
experienced even by Minnesota standards
Super Bowl Sunday will be shivering the
predicted kick-off temperature outside
just nine degrees a three shirt on and a
coat it could be yeah very cold but it's
very pleasant Kevin Smith is part of the
Super Bowl host committee he says
there's a plan for fans who didn't
prepare for cold we have a level one
trauma center within a couple blocks of
US Bank Stadium if anybody has a problem
organizers of this year's Super Bowl are
hoping a million fans embrace the cold
what they call the bold north how many
layers do you have on I think four
layers Eric Dayton helped coin the
phrase he wants to turn the state's snow
and ice into a strength a lot of people
kept saying Super Bowl in February in
Minnesota this sounds like a terrible
idea
well I think it's a great idea and and
it's been so fun to see all of these
out-of-towners outdoors experiencing
what we have to offer okay
like ziplining across the Mississippi
River a hundred feet in the air all week
many of the activities have been held
outdoors with people showing up layered
up and a Winter Carnival is being held
outside and st. Paul where it's expected
a half a million people will come see
this ice palace the city is full of
energy right now and it's it's fun to
see all these people coming to our part
of the country and hopefully they're
gonna go home with great stories and
tell me now at all these winter events
there are warming houses set up every
few feet that's because they don't want
people in the cold too long in
single-digit temperatures frostbite can
set in in just 30 minutes
Alix warming house sounds incredible you
guys in Minneapolis stay warm Jamie